want to just get something to eat man I
don't know what the [ __ ] is there's
nothing out here this is a bust these
ribs USA still out here their little rib
joint Donald's with a Spanish tile on
top of it if you're gonna build a
McDonald's you have to make it look like
the neighborhood you will adjust to us
before you sell your poison thank you
very much it's not right there get the
[ __ ] out there like I did nothing wrong
I already turned yellow but you know
whenever you go to make a left you want
to try to make sure three people there's
a person texting while they walk across
the street should we legally be able to
drive by open your door and hit him I
think actually yeah he'll fight with
this guy he's walking across the
crosswalk and the arrow was green and
this person didn't go I was like what
the [ __ ] and then they finally went I
tried to make the light by then people
were in the crosswalk thing and he was
this Mexican dude yo bro that says walk
I was like the lights green I could tell
he was gonna do something to my truck
and at the last second before he walked
away he slapped my mirrors something
like that and then I said all this
Steven Seagal [ __ ] at him as he walked
away as if I could beat the [ __ ] out of
him with my fucked-up ribs messed up
shoulder in my lack of quick twitch
muscle fiber but you know when you're in
your car you feel safe in an out burger
there's always a line I think when you
get a pedestrian mad enough to slap the
mirror off the side of your car I mean
that's usually a good indication that
you know you probably not interacting
with your fellow man the way you should
be
Firehouse Subs you're like that's a
great name huh just sounds like you're
gonna get diarrhea there's a fire in my
ass thanks for the subs would you like
some peppers on that no I wouldn't
Firehouse Subs that beautiful woman
coming out of [ __ ] Domino's Pizza
gorgeous look at that dog right there
I don't care in the world I think he
gives a [ __ ] about global warming does
it
somebody could write a great coffee
table book about that about how to get
into the mentality of a dog with its
head out the window and there'd be
enough [ __ ] morons out there that
would buy it and literally start driving
down the street like Ace Ventura
like this lady yeah go ahead go ahead
yes god bless you in your hat god bless
you and your hat and your hat and your
dog that's not safe that's not safe
I have children have dogs right that's
what Bob Barker used to say spay and
neuter yourselves and have more cats and
dogs
another hipster guy with his tight jeans
he's never having kids
that's why these Millennials and ever
and you know they're not having kids the
way other generations have it's not
they're not trying I mean everybody's
out there bang and it's just when you're
James of that type it's just you know
it's killing an entire generation dude
there's like a ramen place every five
feet I don't understand what people are
so excited about [ __ ] ramen noodles
for even if they taste good you want to
sit around another 20 people making that
noise [ __ ] Hannibal Lecter fava beans
noise the entire time you got to get
ramen noodles to go that's it to go item
but they should make you sit outside on
a windy day when you eat it so no one
has to listen to you slurping this [ __ ]
up no matter how broke I was I never
drove a car like that at some point you
just got to take out the credit card and
get the [ __ ] back bumper fixed you
don't accept it the second you reattach
the license plate you just accepted you
that's like you put on some pounds and
rather than eating a salad you buy the
next size up pants right you just
accepted the fact that you're slowly
gonna become a fat [ __ ] you know these
[ __ ] people with their bumpers in
their countries I've just had
there it is ribs USA I should probably
shut the car off global warming and all